[Applause]
thank you today I'm going to talk about
running shiny without a server uh but
before I get there uh it's come to my
attention that there some people in our
community might not know what a server
even is and that's totally okay a server
is a computer that's running 247
connected to the internet and it stands
ready at all times to serve up your
shiny app using r or python which makes
sense our apps are written in r or
python so if you want to share your
shiny app with other people you need a
server it it is a requirement and it has
to be running r or Python and that
server can take many shapes and sizes
this is a Raspberry Pi that is a totally
cromulent server and uh you could have
servers like this uh those are actually
buildings in Toronto but they kind of
look like servers so I was like
sure and uh posit and other places in
the shiny Community make it pretty easy
actually to get your app onto a server
you might not even know that there's a
server on the other side and we have
stuff for the cloud we have stuff for on
Prem we have stuff that's free we have
stuff that's uh Enterprise priced and
they all do um a great job at the
different things that they
do but they all have trade-offs right
they all have different pros and cons
and different trade-offs between cost
scalability and
features and this is especially annoying
to
academics I think uh when there are um
maybe pretty severe resource constraints
on what's available to them and yet
there are things that they want to
express with shiny and not just
academics but I'm going to pick on them
because um I think I hear it a lot from
them and uh what they hate is this that
the cost is proportional to the amount
of computational complexity in your app
and the number of users so um that might
have nothing to do with how much money
they have available a um but it's
something that is a reality for them
nonetheless so um I think for a lot of
academics I talk to especially but also
some hobbyists and Freelancers their
attitude is like this wouldn't it be
easier if it all just blew
away and for a long time that was a
total pipe dream uh but a few years ago
I started to hear Rumblings about this
thing called Web assembly or wasum and
I'm going to give you the shortest
description of wasum that I can what is
wasum well before wasum there was just
JavaScript the browser only spoke one
programming language and it was
JavaScript and it didn't matter how you
felt about JavaScript if you wanted to
Target the browser that was the language
you had to write in and nowadays
browsers speak two languages they're
still JavaScript and now there's this
new thing called wasum but they are
different because wum was designed for
humans to write and wum is designed for
compilers to emit so you don't write
wasm as a human being you write code in
something like C or C++ you compile it
to wasum and that wasm then runs in the
browser now let's talk about why this is
exciting and before we can I have to
come clean and admit to you all that I
was wrong about wasum that I was a huge
skeptic of all this and I'm going to
explain why and
um a lot of people within the company
and some people outside of the company
would hear about wasm however they hear
about things and come to me or come to
our team and say I have this great idea
I have had this breakthrough in
reasoning shiny is written in r r is
written in
C++ C++ can be compiled to wasum
therefore shiny can be compiled to wasum
QED let me know when it
chips right and this is a chain of
reasoning that occurred independently to
multiple people over multiple years and
um each time we would have this
discussion and I would have to uh
disappoint them and my response
eventually was like well actually let me
school you on what's Happening Here
compiling C and C++ to wasum is just the
tip of a gigantic Iceberg this is the
biggest Iceberg I could find on unsplash
but if I could make the top smaller and
the bottom bigger I
would because compiling C and C plus
plus to wasm is very exciting but if you
think about what R does and what python
does there's all this stuff under the
surface Beyond just interpreting C and
C++ uh instructions there are all these
things that are uh either from the
operating system or from libraries that
we've built on over the years and they
are not available in
wasum and it's not just a matter of
rebuilding those pieces that are missing
because the environment that wasm runs
in is the browser and the browser has a
number of limitations that your desktop
computer is not subject to in the
browser you cannot launch a process you
can't open a network connection you
can't even perform IO like reading from
a disc or or fetching for the network
synchronously you can't handle something
as simple as control
C and wasum does not lift any of these
restrictions uh in and of itself instead
it really just makes it hurt more
because we have this software already
written that's expecting to be able to
do these things and we really wanted to
just make it run in the browser and we
cannot because these things make it so
hard and it makes me think of this
Haitian
proverb day genan and what that means is
beyond mountains more
Mountains whatever Hill you have to
climb whatever obstacle you're facing
whatever challenge you overcome when you
get to the other side it's just more of
the same
and lucky for me lucky for you lucky for
all of us uh not everybody thought like
I did not everybody had the same
reaction that I did to these challenges
because I got to the point where I was
getting pretty frustrated I was like all
right stop suggesting we Port things to
wasum stop trying to make wasum happen
it's not going to
happen and there are some people that
are wired very differently than me that
uh did some pretty amazing things alonza
Kai showed up one day and uh you know on
the internet and said hi I built a
compiler tool chain and Computing
platform that runs on WM that's called M
scripton and this thing is ma I mean as
far as I'm concerned it's magic this is
replacing both the GCC tool chain and uh
big parts of Linux and making them
available in the browser and if that
doesn't mean anything to you all the
more reason you should be grateful that
he's doing this work um Michael boom who
is a complete legend in the python space
and just one more reason why he's a
Legend um just put out a blog post one
day saying oh you know I was curious if
it was possible so I patched numpy Matt
plot lib and pandace the whole
Scientific Python stack now runs in the
browser that's called
pyodide and uh Winston Chang on my team
uh over a weekend did a little bit of
hacking literally over a
weekend okay yeah I I was gone um um and
uh apparently what happens when I'm gone
is people do things I ask them not to
um and and Winston uh showed up one day
and said hey I made shiny run on pide
and that became shiny
life and our own George Stag and LOL
Henry uh came up with well George stag
even before he worked for posit um I
think because he was frustrated that a
class that he was teaching like he
didn't want to stand up a server went
and instead
um did this miraculous thing and created
webar and um it was interesting in
putting together this talk I actually
learned a little bit more about this
saying that uh in Haiti it has really
not just a negative meaning that it is a
meaning that's about yes a grim
situation which which Haiti more than
almost any other country finds itself in
uh perpetually but
there is also sort of a resilience to it
uh this this acknowledgement that
whatever problems we Face we will always
face more problems and that doesn't stop
us from getting up and doing what needs
to be done and in that way it's the same
mountains that they're looking at that
that people like George and um and
Winston and um all the other people
who've contributed to this swom stack
saw the same mountains but instead of
concluding well the challenges will
never end so let's not begin the journey
instead they just decided Well let's see
how far we can go and it turns out that
even though there are more Mountains in
the distance from where we are today
we've come in an awful long
way so this time last year we had the
pleasure to introduce shiny life for
Python and that was super fun this
basically moves this model that I talked
about in the beginning where you have a
server that's running Python and it
flips it on its head so that the server
is running essentially nothing the
server just serves up HTML and
JavaScript and python runs inside of the
browser for everybody who
connects and I am very pleased to tell
you that our estimate from last year
that it would be a couple of years
before we had this for R uh did not take
into account George Stag and today shiny
life for R is
available
Bo it feels incredible to stand up here
and take credit for work I had no part
in so how to use shiny life uh and this
is actually pretty interesting because
everything from here on out applies
equally to R and python there's very
little difference between these two so
let's talk about how we use shiny life
and there are actually three different
options that are
available you can convert you can fiddle
and you can include and I will go
through each of those in
turn
the first option is to convert so you
take your app. R any other code files
you have uh any data files you want and
you pass them into this simple shiny
live export function and that will take
your app directory and turn it into a
completely static set of assets and you
can then take that and upload it to uh
GitHub Pages for example uh this entire
uh presentation um is uploaded to uh
well you'll see it a sec second uh and
this exact same workflow uh also applies
to python except instead of installing
the r shiny live package you just in you
know pip install shiny live and it's the
same
deal so this is a great option if you
want to take your shiny application and
turn it into a standalone
website now one just unfortunate wrinkle
about this is that um due to sort of
browser security rules you cannot simply
double click the HTML file uh that is
you know sitting in this directory when
you're testing on your own machine um
the browser will not let certain
Advanced browser features be used unless
it sees that the URL bar has an HTTP in
it um therefore if you using shiny for R
you would run this HTTP UV command if
you're running shiny for python you
would run that line three python HTTP do
server command uh if you are uploading
your um your shiny your stat shiny app
to a web server then none of this
matters none of this applies okay
details details option number two is
fiddle so we have a website called shiny
life.io how many of you have taken a
look at shiny live IO uh for shiny for
python over the last year okay great so
quite a few and this is a way that you
can write and share shiny apps directly
in the browser no need to install r or
python on your local machine and it
looks like this you have an editor that
you can write code in and uh when you
hit the play button it generates uh The
View on the right and you can fully use
that that's a shiny app that's it still
is crazy to me that this works but it
somehow does work uh that is running
python inside of your browser and you
get a full shiny
app uh shiny for Python and shiny for R
have different links um I will repeat
these Links at the end but just so you
know you cannot go to the you cannot
currently go to the python side and find
a link to the r side or vice versa you
just have to know the rent URL
uh shiny life.io you can view and run
examples that we have created and you
can also create your own apps from
scratch you can also share apps that you
create via URL to your um well to anyone
and you can save apps to GitHub gists if
you
want okay maybe the most exciting one is
option three option three we have a
shiny live Cordo extension so you can
take your Cordo documents and insert
these shiny live- R flavored chunks and
put a fullon shiny app in there and it
is now just when you render it to HTML
you have a shiny app that just works
inside of your HTML
[Applause]
yeah
so uh this is an example uh actually
this came up yesterday I had uh lunch
next to um eron Howard of Oregon State
University and she mentioned this um
Central limit theorem app that she had
built that really helped in um getting
the idea of the central limit theorem
across this is not her app I'm sure hers
was better but I wrote this in the
middle of the night last night um and
you can see here that this is like fully
running it's a shiny app this is a Cordo
document there's no server behind
it so for this app
it's drawing a bunch of samples from a
normal distribution and uh because it's
only 100 samples that blue line is sort
of jumping around the the red which is
the true mean and uh if I increase that
number oh sorry I'm on the wrong
screen yeah you can see that you uh well
you get the idea I don't need to tell
you guys how it
works
it's great to see how many Central limit
theorem fans there are in the audience
yeah uh which brings me to another point
that usually in technology something
gets cheaper great we can do that thing
for less money but sometimes when the
price drops enough you're not just doing
the same thing that you were doing
before for less money you can do
entirely new things and let me give an
example this is a Mainframe computer
this is the
60s that cost millions of dollars and it
was used for weather research or
military
research in the 70s we had mini
computers these were hundreds of
thousands of dollars and maybe medium to
large siiz businesses would use these to
run their accounting
software in the 80s we had PCS that cost
thousands of dollarss and you might
write a ter paper on this or do your
taxes
or play a
game today we have these magical devices
that cost hundreds of dollars and we use
them to check our YouTube channel
subscriber count while we're having a
latte and recently we even have these
Computing devices that cost tens of
dollars and they exist for only for the
purpose of helping you find your
keys so as the price drops the scenarios
drastically change what computers were
good for and what computers are good for
now are entirely different and that
never would have happened without uh
that drastic decrease in
price and that's what we
found well that's what I found maybe
most surprising once I got over the
initial shock that this stuff works at
all was that this is not just about
taking the kinds of apps that we already
write with shiny the things that shiny
was already good good at and making them
cheaper than before we very quickly were
finding new new ways to use shiny that
would not have been possible before and
one is our shiny for Python
tutorial uh has these embedded shiny app
editors bundled throughout our website
throughout our tutorial and this lets
you as someone who's learning shiny for
python interact with the code try
different things and then hit the play
button immediately see what happens and
you can do all this without needing to
install python or shiny on your machine
and this is not something that we had a
did
before and we extended that concept also
to our examples um our shiny for python
website uses a Cordo dooc package and
that package works very nicely with uh
shiny for p shiny live for python so all
of our examples especially the ones that
have anything to do with UI we can have
running examples that will actually
instantiate a new shiny app inside the
browser and show you exactly what
happens this doesn't work yet but you
could certainly imagine that package
down sites for R in general could do
this sort of
thing uh this is the GT package it's an
incredibly beautiful package for
creating tables and you could um yeah
I'd be excited about um GT's
documentation having shiny apps that
help you understand what the different
options
do and there's a group uh from the r
Consortium that's working with the FDA
that are um trying to take web art and
shiny live and see if they can use that
to help um accelerate uh clinical study
reporting by uh bundling shiny apps with
um their clinical uh trial
submissions and this is where I want to
turn it over to you and ask what
possibilities can you find in your work
to take advantage of these new
possibilities for shiny could your next
presentation be more compelling with a
little shiny could your lecture notes
lead to deeper understanding can your
blog posts be more powerful or maybe you
just want to bewilder your students with
a random game of hangman in the middle
of their
homework uh that comment is inspired by
uh Chelsea uh parlet pel who um wrote
one of these I'm not sure why but you
can click on the link and play Hangman
in your
browser so to recap there are these
three ways to use it convert fiddle and
include now uh with my last 30 seconds
there are limitations I wasn't wrong
that this is a challenging Computing
environment to try to do data science in
uh probably the most obvious is that the
slower start time and larger download
sitze because you are downloading your
data python any packages you need or or
R if it's R you're downloading all of
those to your machine um it's really bad
for R right now but over the next couple
weeks it'll be better um and some things
are just not going to work so the native
shiny execution model is not going away
but now we also have shiny live thank
[Applause]
you